so your personal favorite rappers what
like give me your like did you you kind
of just gave me the L
fias
Nas that
[__] juvenile juvie
juvie um [__] um uh
Roy J electronica
I wonder you grow cuz how old are you
we're about the same age 43 okay so
you're older than me you're seven years
older than me when I was a little
kid I was so into No Limit Records yeah
of course ghetto dope was like an
important part of my life yeah and you
wanted to beat him well you wor
camouflage yes I had the I had a I know
I could bro I I had the chain I didn't
have camouflage bro I could see you I
was super poor I didn't have camouflage
I could see you I'm From the Rough
Scrabble areas of Phoenix I could see
you yes actually right now I'll take hey
hey wait wait Phoenix is crazy I'm sure
it is like I I'm not dissing Phoenix by
the way cuz there'll be some [__] name
no Phoenix is crazy I see right now
that's that's how sh Scot that's how
this [__] gets [__] up and then all of
a sudden I get back to my DMs and it's a
[__] named Cactus te that got problems
with me or some [__] like that I did not
Cactus te how is there not been a rapper
Nam cus some [__] that named Cactus te
I'm not dissing Phoenix man I'm not
dissing Phoenix I have my No Limit
though I know you did and a w tank chain
at the same time I bro you had all the
chains you was hopping from crew to crew
like one of these I I can I can see you
at 14 of the of the Rosenberg model no
no it wasn't 14 it was more like like
sixth grade uh it was definitely like um
I would say sixth grade
um fifth sixth grade I would have like
my folder and I could tag up the Ruff
Riders R the Wu tank saying see well
like there's a certain thing for white
boys who really love rap but it's no but
but and I I can all see y'all you know
cuz then when you get to a certain age
then we can't tell you [__] about rap no
more then it's you get to a certain no
I'm not that no no no no no see I you
get to a certain age and you can tell
you can't [__] tell me what common
meant to me in 1995 I drove all the way
from Phoenix to Minneapolis to hear him
spit no I see common in Phoenix though I
see I know you did common in the roots
electric that's a great show by the way
talking about rappers black thought oh
yeah nuts oh yeah nuts Andre 3000 oh
yeah I hope glass that right there I
hope glass Malone hears this glasses
Andre 3000 is one of the top five
rappers of all time I think glasses has
some of the worst hip-hop takes ever and
him and I argue about them all the time
so you know glasses has you know what
y'all let glasses [__] with y'all that's
the problem I my new thing with glasses
is and I know it Burns him up that's my
guy one of the most solid people no he's
the best my my favorite thing with
glasses is now there's his his album's
up there on tape three words I say the
glasses agree to disagree cuz he doesn't
want that nope that's not what he wants
glasses glasses would come in there sit
down he tried to sit here and say Drake
wasn't hip-hop and and oh that's a
that's a that's a star Worth right there
and he tried to say well I got to think
about whether or not Kanye's hip-hop
because he grew up in the middle class
home yeah I mean that's just once again
the Drake isn't hip-hop thing he said
444 isn't a hip-hop album which is a
wild thing to right so I mean that's
these are these are see you guys are
this is glassos 101 I'm talking about
the next and then his tweets his tweets
he he be throwing [__] out on Twitter
I'm just like I ain't even going to
engage today he believes it though one
of the smartest guys ever T and and just
one of the people that like when you go
against him it'll make you smarter no no
glasses is great no he's just got some
crazy takes but yeah so it's those guys
I'm trying to think who else obviously I
love Kendrick Lamar yeah
um so like a lot of people that I listen
to a whole hell of a lot like uh lyrics
of Fury Rakim I love raim that's one of
my favorite songs one of if you caught
me in like
97 I was bumping like the 18th letter
crazy I was going to say I actually the
first rock him album I ever owned was
the 18th letter mhm and then I kind of
like went back and got like paid in full
and I like would I go back and kind of
just go through like Five mik albums in
the source and go buy them and catch up
you know things seem the same and the
whole scene is Lay I come in Grain with
the Unexplained with the brain things
change the all that [__] that [__] he
he on another level he's the Marlin
Brando hipop it was cool meeting Rock
Kim as I was I think it was like see
what I'm saying see see no I'm saying
like it was see like like like you you
see that's this is what I'm talking
about no I was let me tell my story it's
not about Let Me Tell Your Story it's
about that moment probably means so much
to to to to Kev that when he meets a new
black and this is not the first time why
is everything racial cuz it is not you
don't want it to be what do we you don't
want it to be you don't want hip hop to
be for black people you don't think it
is I didn't say that okay so then why
can't I say why can't I say you're white
what I was going to say I was trying to
tell my story you're white I'm black
look at this take a picture of this this
is the this is the from me and
ble but what I'm saying is this that
meant so much to you because he saw you
for the first time no far did you have
to drive no what I was trying to say was
it was cool when I met Rockin because I
met him with like a lot of my homies
that are like much older than me right
so like they like like were listening to
him like like when he was it was rockim
and er Eric B oh wow so for me like of
course Rock Kim's rockim right but it
was just dope to see like like kind of
like it was like my homies like they're
Jay-Z to kind of see them and the way
they were just like and I was like
excited but but to them it was like
everything to meet Rock Kim you know
what I'm saying are you familiar with
the history of
Hollywood I'm I mean I wouldn't say I'm
extremely familiar I mean I I would say
I'm Vaguely Familiar there you go it's a
good answer I mean I think that we're
all Vaguely Familiar mean live here yeah
here you go um what this is why I say
he's the the Marlon Brando of rap all
right this is my explanation for this so
method acting comes in you know Marlon
Brando and you know everybody from the
Stella allers school and um different
all of that stuff Strasburg and all that
uh method acting comes in and it changes
acting right because there's a you know
you guys you know old Hollywood very
Earnest
say all that stuff then you have guys
that um you have a different School of
acting that comes in which is based in
realism um synthesizing the character uh
taking that character's emotions and
then making them real real
grounded uh portrayals of people that
are that affect you in a different way
um and then every Everything changes
after him mhm right not necessarily the
inventor of it but the single symbol of
when everyone started to sound different
right right like he was kind of the the
Because of Him everyone applied
themselves rapping right so after Brando
this is Van's opinion because I know
there's somebody out there uh after
Brando then the next generation of
actors that come in a little bit after
that particularly in the
Jack Nicholson Hoffman all of these guys
and these guys take uh like Pacino Dao
these guys uh interpret drama in a
different way to me rockim is the bridge
between Co rapping the rest of those
guys too but he's the he's the bridge
between all of that and just thinking of
a mass I'm just on this [__] and I'm
just spit right and there are other guys
that are there too but when I think
about what it changed and how people are
are different I'm I'm going to get on
this [__] I'm you think of him
and then you think of the sound totally
[__] changing at least for lyri for
lyricism there are other guys out there
that are in that situation I'm sure that
ninth wonder and sway are like f we GNA
call you and tell you a different
situation because those are the two most
knowledgeable hip-hop guys I've ever
talked to in the phone I I've never I
met ninth Wonder once in St Louis at a
bar n wonder is a [__] Encyclopedia
of hip-hop